من الواضح الآن أن إرادة
الحزب البرلماني المحافظ
يجب أن يكون هناك زعيم جديد لذلك
الحزب وبالتالي رئيس وزراء جديد
وقد اتفقت مع سيجرين برادي
رئيس مجلس النواب الخلفي من
خلال عملية اختيار هذا الزعيم الجديد
يجب أن نبدأ الآن
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
ثقة في أدوارنا قد تم تقويضها من
خلال سلسلة من الفضائح
ولكن الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكننا التحكم فيه
هو قيمنا وسلوكياتنا ،
لذا من الضروري علينا
جميعًا وضع معايير عالية  من أجل أنفسنا
واتخاذ الإجراءات عندما لا
يقابلهم الآخرون
عندما تكون الأوقات صعبة عندما
تواجه الدولة ضغوطًا على الاقتصاد
وضغوطًا على ميزانياتها السيد
سبيكر وعندما تكون لدينا أكبر حرب في
أوروبا منذ 80 عامًا ، السيد المتحدث
عندما يكون ذلك  هي بالضبط اللحظة التي
تتوقع فيها أن تواصل الحكومة
عملها حتى لا تنسحب
[موسيقى]
أجنبية